continúa la conmoción en Francia líderes
de extrema derecha convocaron a una
manifestación este jueves en París para
demostrar la indignación que ha causado
el asesinato de Lola David una niña de
12 años a manos de una extranjera con
estatus migratorio y regular la
manifestación comenzó con un momento de
silencio y fue aprovechada por diputados
como Erick semuc y Marín de pen para
criticar las políticas migratorias del
actual gobierno
esto no Data solamente con la llegada de
Emmanuel macrón pero nadie cambia nunca
nada así que nos contentamos con decir
que la ley no se aplica pero eso ya no
es suficiente este caso que estamos
presenciando nos obliga la acción
eficacia las autoridades han atribuido
el crimen a una mujer argeliana de 24
años quien fue puesta bajo custodia de
la policía por los cargos de asesinato
violación tortura entre otros algunos
representantes del gobierno criticaron
la politización del caso de Lola durante
un debate en la asamblea nacional en el
cual se discutían las políticas
migratorias en el país algo criticado
por algunos sectores sin embargo el
gobierno francés reconoció que deben
haber cambios en el tema
obviamente tenemos que hacerlo mejor y
estamos trabajando duro como dijo
nuevamente el ministro del interior en
sus declaraciones para que podamos
garantizar que se haga un seguimiento
los padres informaron sobre la
desaparición de su hija el viernes en la
tarde ya que no regresó a su casa de la
escuela pocas horas después de activar
los protocolos de búsqueda su cuerpo fue
hallado dentro de una caja en el patio
del edificio en el que habitaba